hello welcome to the GameSpot stage
right here at e3 2014 it's the last demo
of the day it's not fair we played so
much but stuff come h1z1 phoenix rage
dub Juarez landmark as I just throw
caution to the wind and read directly
from my sheet instead of pretending like
I know all of this information already
I'm very happy to be light about Aaron
Webber from Sega hey there my friends
very good happy to be here yeah you're
here with Hatsune Miku Project Diva F
2nd you got it you got the title man
this sequel to Padme have a handsome a
Miku project EMF that's correct
first of all I've my good friends at
Giant Bomb Jeff Grossman and Brad
shoemaker I've been giving me the
lowdown on the cultural reference here
and I feel like anyone who is I'm sure
they're people watching the stream and
people are here who know exactly the
[ __ ] going on and they're wondering
why I'm even explaining this ok the
folks at home who don't hats any Miko
just the overall concept of who she is
on her a culture of in Japan let's let's
do it let me give me the Reader's Digest
version so for all you viewers out there
like what's a Hatsune Miku's yeah let me
explain it to you you guys know how
GarageBand was created so if you didn't
have a guitarist so you can add a guitar
to the music that you were creating
Hatsune Miku is actually faced and
originated in much the same way but for
vocals so if you had a band but you
didn't have a singer you could use the
Miku software to create music and so
people start making music in Japan with
this program and suddenly some really
good musicians pop up right of people
going man who's the singer that I'm
hearing in these amazing songs and the
internet happens and everything starts
going viral yeah and so that's how Miku
actually began she's a virtual singer
she's the world's most famous virtual
singer she has over 2 million English
Facebook Likes yeah which is kind of
amazing right she had a concert in 2011
here in Los Angeles it sold out in like
15 minutes haven't have any people who
are it filled the Nokia oh really like
active right she's huge and she's just
growing and getting bigger she just
opened for Lady gaga over the last
couple months so head is now is it did
it dude guerilla style where it's some
sort of a 3d representation yeah it's
like a hologram these are on the stage
and a full 3d projection it's really
tense and and they just announced it
back I have this lovely car there they
just announced cue concerts that are
gonna happen this year one in Los
Angeles and one in New York come October
so really really exciting stuff but let
me tell you bit more about the games
that's probably where here let's talk of
video games
gamespot not I like Kotaku here when I
we can't yet do it I got I got a little
rant actually mind if I do my rant go
for it all right guys I'm talking to you
gamers you guys at home you guys that
play your battlefields in your Call of
Duty's and you're titanfall's right and
some of you never play any game except
those games and I want to say guys
that's a shame because there are so many
amazing games out in the world that you
guys may have never played and right now
I want to show you one of those games
and I want to show you why those are the
kind of games you guys need to check out
Maura I swear to god man if this whole
you know talking about video game stuff
doesn't work the WWE would obviously
love you that is how you cut a solid
promo fantastic let's do it yeah show
bright tell me okay I am I am video
gamer X who is absolute piece of garbage
you only plays call of duty hey no no no
that doesn't make you piece of garbage
alright there's not just because you
liked oh no no no every game is
respectable and it's always what is use
but okay what I want to say though is
that there's so many games to get over
Lux right now and and so many games that
do like oh I don't know about that I'm
not gonna check that out but I
challenged many gamers today to get out
there like expand your horizons check
out games will normally check out this
game is a rhythm game so what you're
seeing on the screen here is Hatsune
Miku and the other characters these are
all owned by Krypton it's a rhythm game
when you just tap the button store like
tapping Circle Circle Circle Circle
really easy right so maybe you played
like some guitar hero or say I have been
known to play other rhythm games in yeah
I even played some donkey konga
fantastic so let's say you've never
played a rhythm game yeah in your life
right if you're a viewer that's like I
am I couldn't do this don't worry that's
what this mode is we're looking at easy
mode right okay and for you experienced
rhythm gamers we're gonna get into some
harder modes in just a little bit so
you're flicking the thumbstick for the
stars there right and then you're just
tapping the circle button and that's all
it is in easy mode super simple rhythm
game and a lot of people come up and
they play it right and they're like
oh this looks kind of fun alright I like
try it and after like 30 seconds second
they're like tapping along and then you
see their head start to Bob yeah it
starts to tap on the ground and then by
the end they're like you know I have no
idea what this game is but I'm totally a
dick right now and that's getting like
this like guilty pleasure like for some
reason they feel bad about liking it but
they're yeah what and the Japanese
culture stuff is really like growing
quite a bit anime Khan's around the
nation I have record attendance year
after year Anime Expo is coming up in
July here in Los Angeles and so there's
a lot of stuff going on the next song
we're gonna look at is slightly harder
song it's actually one of the songs that
was that first really popular miku song
it's called the world is mine so when do
we when these songs are being released
she would be there because it was a
piece of software and a lot of people on
access to because it different people
releasing the songs or is it is it now
one company owns it alright so check
this out
yeah so a lot of these guys have their
own labels a lot of them are under a
label that's owned by Krypton okay but
when these guys are coming out with the
music very often there's these creative
internet communities and one guys like
well I can write music but I'm not a
good artist like okay raw anything and
then another guys look well I can do the
art but I couldn't do a music video and
so then they find another guy on mine
he's like well I'll do the music video
crazy it's kind of an amazing story
because it's like all of these creative
types and people coming together to
create this final piece which is the
music with the special costume with the
video in our game we actually have over
150 costumes which is really amazing and
all of those costumes the modules as we
call them were created by different
people around the world so it's like all
this user creation the game itself has
40 different songs in it we're showing
we're gonna show you agree today we must
show you a couple of the harder ones and
in addition to that though it also has a
mode called the diva room and in the
deeper room you can go kind of hang out
with the virtual Idol oh thank god now
the Giant Bomb guys really love that but
let me tell you I've seen it since out
but beyond that mode there's also an
edit mode a demo is really cool because
that's where what you're seeing on
screen you could go do this yourself so
you could say well creature oh you can
not only create your own from like
positioning the camera telling the
character where to move what enemy
you can use their own music and you can
add in your own buttons and then you can
upload those to PSN and they can be
ranked and voted on by different people
and helping is the game is coming out
for both PlayStation 3 and PlayStation
Vita yes those will be able to talk to
each other so not only can you do that
with leaderboards but there's also gonna
be cross save compatibility so you're at
work you're somewhere else you know not
home you're playing it on your feet on
your leg this is awesome but then you go
home and because it's press save all the
work that you've done is gonna translate
GPS so when you said you can import your
own songs is that mean as I like any
song alright that's any friendly yeah
it's a what's your favourite band of the
Deftones Jeff towns you want to make a
Deftones song with the meek you engine
you can do that stuff you can upload it
to PSN and all the other gemstones fans
would be like this is the best I almost
feel like you shouldn't I almost feel
like if you're gonna like you know
experiences for what it is for like
further the style the aesthetic like
that the music is like index early like
that's what the genesis of all this was
sure like if it not authentic its kind
of I would say I wouldn't even worry
about that because the cool thing about
miku and about all of this stuff is that
it's all about user creation it is about
the enjoyment of people making really
amazing things and those things becoming
really popular so don't worry about
offending anybody okay if you make a
depth on when I upload might be quiet
and drive video I'm a hits in amico I
will I would feel pretty good about it
I will download it for you for you don't
worry as its company-owned Vita on ps3
and are you guys got a ps4 version at
all the works no just just
Vita and ps3 one of the things that's
different this time this game has a
really amazing story actually this the
first game almost never came out in the
West yes it was very close to never
happening and we did a Facebook post and
this was like our last-ditch attempt we
had to convince the executives that this
game would be worth bringing out right
so we did a Facebook post it said like
it and share it if you want to see this
game in the West and God bless you Sega
fans and maybe fans because you guys
they went on Facebook they liked it they
shared it it became the most liked and
shared thing that Sega's ever done in
history across any I think more than
sonic take that Sonic and and so I love
Sonic but we were really happy to see
that and so thanks to that we were able
to convey
everyone's to let that first game come
out and then when was that was that like
two years ago this was actually last
August Oh was it Wow really you guys
working yeah and the Vita version of the
first game only came out in March oh wow
well how much of a delay was there
between the original Japanese release um
what agreement we managed to do it with
about a six-month delay stopped us which
is not bad at all and a lot of people
look at a Japanese game and they might
go oh I mean it's just a rhythm game
what do you have to do you just kind of
like localize a couple menu bits right
no no who my friends there is so much so
much more to it than that and the guys
playing right now he is Sam ball and Sam
is our producer he's so passionate about
Miko and he's one of the guys that can
tell you that his whole job I'd say it
was like getting this thing ready to go
into months and months and months of
time so tons of work goes into it but
thanks you know to the front reception
of the first game yeah just doing really
well like we released it and we're like
oh please fans like put your money where
your mouth let's go buy this game like
we want to bring out you know these kind
of games have the heavy to do that when
it wouldn't eventually came out yeah and
and thanks to that like they all did it
and that's what what made us able to go
all right we're gonna do the sequel and
the Vita version did not come out as a
physical copy and I remember posting on
the Sony blogs and the Sony fans man
they're like we really want a physical
version why is there no physical copy
and so when we were coming up with the
second one I'm never ready to sing
anything like we have to do a physical
version for the PS Vita for all the Vita
owners out there and we are so excellent
I'm not surprised because it seems like
this is a very dedicated fanbase and one
of the nicest things is just having a
physical version of any game that you
are thinking was that like if you like
these kind of games you like the
Japanese games you know some of the
niche games right you like having that
on your bookshelf - you like being able
to look at it be like this thing is so
shiny
I'm glad I bought this you know that
that kind of moment is nice all right so
are we looking at something hard here
cuz I gotta be honest this looking
pretty hard this is hard mode my bread
in a hard mode this is for all you
experience rhythm gamers out there those
arrows what you're doing is you're
tapping the direction of the arrow and
like the Meerut button on the right side
so if it's like the down arrow it's down
in X okay triangle triangle square
square X X these music videos are
amazing the game is developed by Sega of
Japan
all of these videos have little extras
hidden without them and if you're in
them what we're going to see coming up
is actually gonna be a let's call chance
times chance time happens in every song
it's where you gonna see some rainbow
colored streaks flowing with cymbals as
they come up on the screen if he gets
chance time right what's gonna happen is
that something special will happen in
the video at some point and they're a
little Easter eggs across there we're
crossing our fingers from I think you
can do it
that's a tech zone right there tech
zones are little bits of the song where
they feel kind of a hard time by you and
if you manage to mail all the notes you
get a store boost the bar at the bottom
of the screen that you can see there by
the bottom of the screen is how he's
progressing so far we have a song and
some are doing very well so keep it up
Sam you're rockin it man here's the
chance time see those rainbow yeah yeah
I know so he's trying to get it he needs
to fill that Safari option bottom left o
do a pro oh right get it that's alright
alright you might have time for one more
hopefully he'll get it on that one so
the game itself like really easy to get
into super simple to start off on but
also surprisingly complex so those of
you that love complex rhythm games you
want a big challenge with everything
games worry not and hard mode actually
is not the hardest mode I'm just gonna
throw it out there there's one called
extrema not surprised which is about
maybe 30 to 50 percent harder than what
you're seeing right here can we see some
extreme modes not that today lots but
tell you what if you have if you have
Google and YouTube yes you can no no you
don't armies nothing for another five
minutes you don't have Google you stay
here you stay here Google no do not go
to Google right now and one of the one
of the biggest moments of playing rhythm
games where they've got like this
amazing animation nonsense happening in
the background is that often you're just
too busy for bringing in the buns we is
there motor on look at them yes they've
literally thought of everything yes
there is the mode where you can just
watch the video right so another cool
thing is you can change out all of the
modules or the costumes that you see in
these videos so let's say you're like my
favorite character isn't meet you I
really like Ren or LAN or Kaito you can
swap out Miku for these other care okay
and the music video will progress as
normal with that special character that
costume
ours are those are those other
characters known within the wider
yeah like Miku universe like us yes they
are they actually all have their own at
you
sound banks now in the game it won't
swap out the sound bank it's just a
character but we have different songs by
those characters in the game so every
character has a song will you hit them
singing you're gonna see them actually
in this video right here and that's one
of the extra costumes for Miku you'll
notice that's not her regular default
outfit yeah sad what are the questions
at Devin's us is there a model viewer
for like for the characters themselves
just feel like going to look at the
camera there is something like that when
you're swapping out the modules and the
costumes and you can kind of like take a
look at them I wouldn't call it a
full-fledged model viewer but you can
definitely look at all the modules
before you use them in a song this is
some mega fanservice going higher yeah
yeah this is this game with such a
passion my golfing [ __ ] eyes do you
feel doing applies here keep up you can
do this in the bottom right what you're
seeing there are two of the challenge
items that Sam is stacked on to make it
harder okay here watch this like man I
can taste that this is easy this game
wasn't challenging enough visually as it
was and it sounds crazy man but like the
more you play it the better you'll get
at it and this this kind of stuff does
become pretty easy yeah and so when you
get to that level you're like I'm ready
for the next step and that's when you
confer on challenge items to get more
diva points that the diva points are how
you buy and unlock items in the game
okay buy items for their room you can
buy new costumes with those and so if
you're going to take a little risk by
throwing a big challenge in there that's
where you get this kind of stuff coming
in Aaron I think you're converting me
here also we just got super loud I love
it it's like the world of at cinemas
we're projecting wider into the
projected Hatsune Miku everywhere how
good you are being a promo dude anything
else we should know about a Hasina miku
PlayStation Vita Playstation 3
that's right it's coming out this fall
you can pre-order it right now okay a
digital and it'll be coming up packaged
and digital history MP 2 simultaneous
all on the same day this fall we'll be
announcing when that is very soon
awesome I came to this to be completely
ignorant I think I'm leaving a fan I
remember back absolute pleasure having
on the stage and before I leave you and
we all disappear into the ether
and what else have you seen around III
have you been at e3 before oh this is my
sixth year oh wow four thousand six year
yeah I saw giant
evolve statue in the huge obviously I
saw sonic boom and all of our cool stuff
for that and I'm really interested now
to finally see this hall and see what
first part you said oh if you haven't
been over okay it's my first time here
since you guys are in this [ __ ]
that's right all right so come come see
the Sega booth in the other hall yeah
and I'm excited to see this stuff I'm
waiting I'm waiting to try and get over
there every single time I get over there
two things happen one I turn up late to
I meet hip-hop gamer every single year
hip-hop gamer he better dress me once
didn't you benchpress me in an interview
via Kusa like years ago yeah I've got I
got some stories with hip hop gamer let
me tell you speaking of Yakuza Yakuza 5
North America I don't have any news on
that come on
no news you seem to me to go to talk to
you to guess Miche popular games to the
west I'm the guy for all things meek you
if you want to talk about song I can
tell about sonic but I don't have any
news on other other IP we know there's a
lot of fans out there that love that
stuff I love it - man yeah all right no
worries
you've got enough Betty today I earn a
pleasure thank you I thanks everyone for
watching